Where there's life,
there's bound to be music.
That's not to say that
one causes the other,
but there's a reason
that silent forests
are a spooky portent of doom.
In many mythologies,
music is associated with
the explosion of life
and bursts of creativity.
But it's also used to explore
the dark side of human nature,
the desire to manipulate
our surroundings,
or to control others.
Every time we play
a musical instrument,
be it a cosmic conch shell,
an emotionally
intelligent harp,
or a heartbreaking lyre,
we are creating something
beautiful and mysterious,
but we're also
manifesting our will.
This tension is evident in the
stories we tell about music,
the instruments that make it,
and the people that perfect it.
[upbeat music]
In some cultures, the sound
of music is associated
with the blooming
of life itself.
Hindu cosmology depicts one
of the principle deities,
Vishnu, holding a shanka,
or conch shell.
During the Churning
of the Cosmic Ocean,
Vishnu knew blew
the conch shell
to sound the first
noise of creation,
an "ommm" that
continues to reverberate
throughout the universe.
With its concentric spirals
and deep echoing sound,
the shanka is
a material manifestation
of eternal cosmic energy.
Other creation myths reveal
the importance of music
to humans from the beginning.
Sumerian myth offers us
the tale of Ninmah
the primeval mother goddess
who shaped the first humans
from fresh underground water.
Her son Enki, crowned
the second ever human
to grace the earth,
a master of the musical
arts and a chieftain,
indicating both
the sacred nature of music
and its centrality
to human nature.
Exploring the links
between life, music,
and creativity is
a common mythical theme.
In Norse mythology,
Bragi, son of Odin,
was given a magical harp
and sent on his way to Asgard
from his mother's home
in the Land of Giants.
With his harp and the magical
runes carved on his tongue,
Bragi's music had the power
to bring plants to life,
control animals,
and ward off harmful spells.
In these stories, music doesn't
just play in the background.
Instead, it actively has
the power to awaken the world.
From epic cosmic ripples to
the most delicate flower.
If music has these epic powers,
it's no surprise that mythical
characters have used it
to exert their will
on the world.
The leader of the Tuatha De
Danann from Irish mythology
was Dagda, a figure of plenty.
His cauldron was always
bubbling with stew,
his pig was always growing,
and his magical club had the
power to either wound or heal.
But perhaps his most
powerful instrument
was his four-angled harp,
also known as the Uaithne.
Also called the Coir Ceathar
Chuir or Four Angled Music,
the harp could put the
seasons in the correct order
and control human emotions.
No big deal.
The Uaithne was
coveted for its powers
by the fairy King Brush.
But when he got his
thieving hands on it,
the harp fell silent.
For no one but the Dagda
could make it sing.
When Dagda uttered
a charm from afar,
the harp came to life and
rushed toward its master
killing nine of the
king's men on route.
Another tale of music's
ability to control comes to us
in the legend of the Owl Husband
from the Passamaquoddy people
in the northeastern U.S.
The story tells of a young
woman who refused to marry.
Her father decreed that
whoever made the embers
of a fading fire
blaze with new flames
could marry his daughter.
Of course, no one could
reverse the fires,
except for the wily horned owl
who disguised himself
as a handsome hunter
and used his magical powers
to reignite the fire.
It was only after their
first night together
that the woman perceived
his yellow eyes
and pointed ears.
Horrified, she fled.
The owl tried to
trick her again,
coming to her in
a different disguise,
but she was able to
perceive his true nature
and she alluded him
for a second time.
Furious, he consulted
his sorcerer owl aunt
who fashioned a magic flute
with the power
to send anyone who heard
its tones into a love trance.
At the sound of sweet music
coming from the forest,
the young woman was enchanted.
By the time she found
herself deep in the forest
searching for her love,
the horned owl swooped down
and snatched
her up in his talons.
So music in mythology
is usually beautiful,
but it often holds
the power to manipulate.
In the harp that toys
with human emotions
or the flute that entrances
unsuspecting mortals,
music is seen as a mysterious
and overwhelming force
that's not to be taken lightly.
This complex power is
further explored in myths
that examine music as a portal
to the supernatural world.
In Finnish mythology,
the demigod Vainamoinen
plucked fish bones
from the base of a waterfall
to fashion a magical harp.
Only he could control
its joy-bringing powers
until the sea god Ahto
stole it for himself.
Stung, Vainamoinen
wove a second harp
from birchwood and
a maiden's golden locks.
He took his new harp with
him deep into the underworld
on a hunt for the Sampo,
a magical device that
could bring good fortune.
With the help of the harp,
Vainamoinen found the Sampo
and lulled the inhabitants
of the underworld to sleep.
Only for them to awaken and
overtake him at the last minute.
Eventually, the Sampo
was lost forever.
Like Vainamoinen,
the Greek hero Orpheus
could only wield his music
against supernatural forces
to a point.
Orpheus was known as the
most masterful musician
who perfected the lyre and
sang stunning love poems.
When his beloved wife
Eurydice died by viper attack,
Orpheus ventured into
the underworld to
beg for her return.
With his haunting lyre,
he played sweet
and mournful music
to tame the
three-headed guardian
of the underworld Cerberus,
and softened the hearts of
gods Hades and Persephone.
The gods of the underworld
agreed to let Eurydice
follow Orpheus back to
the land of the living
on the condition that
Orpheus did not look back
to check that she
was following him.
Just as they neared the surface,
Orpheus was overcome
with anxious curiosity.
He turned around only to
see Eurydice falling back
into the clutches of Hell.
He was so distraught
that he spent the
rest of his life alone
singing about broken hearts.
Until a volatile group of
women, known as the Maenads,
ripped him to shreds
for his lack of cheer.
Orpheus' severed head
carried on singing in death
and so his music
continued to resound.
Here, music is the key
to the underworld,
but it also transcends
tragic circumstances
and retains its mysterious
power beyond the grave.
Orpheus's singing head is not
the only ancient instrument
with supernatural associations.
In Chinese mythology,
Lin Lun was believed to
be the creator of music
who invented the
ancient bamboo flute
and tuned it to mimic
the sound of the phoenix.
To the Nahuas people who
lived in what is now Mexico,
the Death Whistle signaled...
[Death Whistle screaming]
you guessed it, that
someone was going to die.
It was constructed from stone
and carved with symbols of
death like skulls and owls.
While its exact
uses are not known,
scholars have suggested
that their players use them
to echo the howling
wind of the spirit world
in funereal or
sacrificial rituals.
In these examples,
musical instruments
mediate the relationship
between human, natural,
and spiritual worlds.
Making these instruments
from natural materials
and training the body
to play them are acts
that are grounded in
the physical world.
But when played,
these instruments evoke
something intangible
and mystifying.
Across mythology,
stories about music often
come down to the question
of what we can
and can't control.
Tales of music nudging
nature into bloom,
exploiting human emotion,
or communicating
with divine entities,
we see characters trying
to direct the world's
most enigmatic forces.
But we also glimpse
the power of music
to change our perception and
transport us to other realms.
Whether it's being
used for good or evil,
music always retains
a kernel of mystery,
one that often compels us
to surrender our reason
and, hopefully, enjoy the vibes.
Before you go, we want to
invite you to participate
in PBS Digital Studio's
Annual Audience Survey.
It's your chance to tell
PBS what you like to watch
and even vote on new show ideas.
In fact, "Fate and Fabled"
was voted on
in a previous survey,
and here it is today.
So we'd like to thank you for
making this show possible.
And if you'd like to continue
shaping the future of PBS,
there's a link in
the description below.
Thanks!
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.